if you go to this place of creative
Solitude what's your what's your
creative process is there something
you've noticed about what you do that
leads to your to good work
I love to be able not only
to lose focus but kind of to focus on
the peripheral View
and to allow
um different things to occur at once so
I will often in my loneliness Journeys I
will often
uh listen to like Leonard Bernstein
anything I can find online by Lenny
Bernstein it's reading a nature paper
it's War and Peace it's really
revisiting all the texts that are so
Timeless for me with opportunities that
are very very timely and I think for me
the creative process is really about
bringing
timeless
problems or concepts together with
timely Technologies
to observe them I remember when we did
the Mandela Pavilion we Read Moby Dick
the whiteness of the whale the albino
the different the other
and that got us to work on melanin and
melanin also is sort of an output from
the death mask so it's lots of things
happening at the same time and really
allowing them
allowing them to come together to form
this view about the world through the
lens of a spirit being or a living being
or a material and then focus on the
world through the lens of that material
the glass work was another project like
that where we were fascinated by glass
because obviously it's superb material
for architecture
but we created this new glass printing
technology for the first time that was
shedding light on
the biomechanics of fluid glass the math
and the physics of which was never done
before which was so exciting to us but
revealing new knowledge about the world
through technology that's one theme
The Reincarnation between things
material and immaterial that's another
theme
Lenny Bernstein Warren peace Tolstoy
you've tweeted a toaster quote from War
and Peace as of course you would
everything I know I know because of Love
yeah I love this quote so you use these
kind of
inspirations
to focus you and then find the actual
idea in the periphery yes and then
connect them with whatever it is that
we're working on whether it's you know
High throughput directed evolution of
bacteria
um you know whether it's you know
recreating that Garden of Eden and the
capsule and what it looks like the food
of the future
it is a little bit like directing a film
creating a new
project
is a bit like creating a film and
you have these Heroes you have these
characters and you put them together and
there's a narrative and there's a story
whenever we start a new project it has
to have these see these ingredients of
simultaneous complexity it has to be
novel in terms of the synthetic biology
Material Science robotics engineering
all of these elements that are
discipline based or rooted must be novel
if you can combine novelty in synthetic
biology with a novelty in robotics with
a novelty in Material Science with a
novelty and computational design and
bring you are bound to create something
novel period and that's how I run the
company and that's how I pick the people
and so that's another very very
important ingredient of The Cutting Edge
across multiple disciplines that come
together and then in the background in
the periphery there is all these
messages The Whispers of the ancient
oldies right the beethovens and the
picassos is that the Beethoven's always
whispering to you yeah how could one not
include Beethoven and The Whispers